in case you folks don't remember the
great economic crisis that we just came
through was from broke people buying
houses and the stupid government and the
stupid mortgage industry and the stupid
real estate industry and the stupid
culture all of us looking at each other
going Oh broke people should buy houses
it'll be good for them and it wasn't
good for them because when broke people
buy houses it makes them broker that's
why they call them mortgage brokers I
mean do remember that that was 20
minutes ago well apparently the Obama
administration does not remember it this
from the Washington Post the Obama
administration is engaged in a broad
push to make more home loans available
to people with get this weaker credit an
effort officials say will help how are
the economic recovery what are we
covering from an economic nosedive what
was it caused by broke people buying
houses let's try this again one more
time the Obama administration is engaged
in a broad push to make more home loans
available to people with weaker credit
it works so well last time let's do it
again
that was their motto I made that part up
an effort that officials say will help
power the economic recovery but that
skeptics could say could open the door
to risky lending that caused the housing
crash in the first place
count me among the skeptics I'm old I've
seen this three times now ah people
never learn anything from history
President Obama's Economic Advisers and
outside experts say the nation's much
celebrated housing rebound is leaving
too many people behind I'm sorry if you
buy a house and you can't afford it are
you left behind
q the home alone right ah right
are you left behind no you're not left
behind when I sold my home after going
through bankruptcy and moved into a
rental house for two years in order to
get the IRS I mean the KGB paid off was
I left behind
did the economy outpace me and I never
again returned to the elements of
middle-class no I was a renter didn't
kill me it was patients for a peer
of time you people unbelievable
President Obama's Economic Advisers
liberals and outside experts yeah three
of them say the nation's much celebrated
housing rebound is leaving too many
people behind including young people
looking to buy their first homes yeah
they've been out of college for 26
minutes and then bought a house yet dad
blame that's awful and individuals with
weak credit records these credit records
are weakened by the recession all I had
a parenthesis to the end of that to
remind you that was caused by people
with weak credit buying houses why is
this not so freakin simple unbelievable
in response administrative efficient
stricken officials say they're working
to get banks to lend to a wider range of
borrowers by taking advantage of
taxpayer backed programs including those
offered by the Federal Housing
Administration that ensure home loans
against default let me help you what
they were just saying let me make you
sure you understand what Washington just
said you my friends you are the
taxpayers you are backing you are
standing good for you and your
grandchildren and now your
great-grandchildren with this national
debt any defaults by FHA loans by VA
loans administration officials are say
they're working to get banks to lend to
a wider range of borrowers wider range
translation people that shouldn't be
freaking borrowing money
translation more foreclosures
translation more national debt is this
economic recovery chase why is this so
simple to me housing officials are
urging the Justice Department to provide
assurances to banks which have become
increasingly cautious yeah cuz I freaked
and learn their lesson you smack them
till their eyes go crosswise they get it
the government no we'll just do it again
throw the ball throw the ball oh my god
you people unbelievable
housing officials urging the Justice
Department to provide assurances to
banks which have become increasingly
cautious that they will not face legal
or financial recriminations remember the
evil banks that the Obama administration
was going to shut down and they needed
more regulation
because the bankers were just out of
control and they had damaged the a jet
down
they had almost crashed the entire
culture that Wall Street it was their
fault so they needed more regulation and
more control you remember that speech he
got elected last time on it does last
go-around remember remember really I
mean huge liberals you have no sense you
have no sense you really have no sense
it's just it's unbelievable but the
banks need more regulation you know why
because they're evil and they were
making loans to people they shouldn't
have been making but now housing of
Justice Department's providing
assurances saying you will face legal or
financial recriminations no no not like
last time we won't call you the evil
people and highly regulate you even more
than you were before oh not us we're not
the people that did that last time man
this guy they're just they've lost touch
with reality I got to tell you if y'all
don't clean Washington out Republicans -
oh my gosh get a shovel the manure is so
deep I can't breathe I can't this
article blows me away cam you shouldn't
send it to me you're gonna make my blood
I'm simul stress like I had debt or
something though it's just you know I
feel like I've got debt because I guess
I do now it's awful my camera got sent
me this article the Obama administration
is engaged in a broad push to make home
loans available to people with weaker
credit an effort officials say will help
power the economic recovery but skeptics
say could open the door to risky lending
that caused the housing crash in the
first place President Obama's economic
advisors and outside experts say the
nation's much celebrated housing rebound
is leaving too many people behind Ted
leave anyone behind including young
people looking to buy their first homes
because all young people should buy a
house immediately out of college what
are you people idiots and individuals at
credit records weakened by the recession
which was by the way caused by a housing
crash which by the way was caused by
risky lending which according to the
Obama administration was caused by not
enough regulation on mean old evil
greedy banks but now we're going to
reach out to the mean all evil greedy
banks and the Justice Department is
going to provide assurances
that they won't face legal or financial
recriminations but I promise you what we
will do is we will blame you again and
we will bring more regulations your way
just in case you were wondering
subtext Wow I mean I've seen this stuff
cycle back around but it usually takes
at least a decade not four years four
years later we're waiting back into the
stupidity neck-deep does anybody out
there have a brain anymore this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you